[Music]  do  [Music]  icarus was trapped on an island and he  was  in just a closed confined space and he  wanted to fly away from that  so it captures that spirit of flight  that spirit of right now  wanting to reach to someplace else but  also knowing  let's be temperate and let's wait for  the right moment  for the forward motion so we can't have  the folly of icarus either  of flying too quickly and doing anything  that's not  correct  [Music]  little things like covering your face  for  the pandemic it feels kind of like  we're all going through this journey  together and sometimes it's good  sometimes it's bad but  we're here with each other it honestly  it was such a wonderful experience to be  able to perform  four people again that's one of the  reasons why i dance  to be able to show that to everyone is  so rewarding  and so it for me today it's just been  enjoyable  i